thank you
okay so we're in Governor's Island
because
I've been spending way too much time at
home and I figured now would be a really
great time to talk about something that
keeps popping up on my channels on
YouTube and Tick Tock and Instagram
I posted this video on Tick Tock a
little bit ago about
um I was about oh about just saying like
hey learning to code can be a great mix
for people who aren't um super creative
to go freelance rap but don't want to be
the corporate corporate and you're
pretty much the number one comment I got
under that video was like oh well
software Engineers are about to be
replaced anyways like what's the point
and I
I'm like okay this needs to be addressed
there are some things that one obviously
um is scary about the world and climate
right now in terms of AI and Tech really
great and beautiful and exciting but
also in terms of jobs and some jobs like
software engineering like developing
can be at risk so let's talk about all
of it I don't want misinformation to
stop people from going towards uh going
towards their goals you know so let's
get into it this video isn't just going
to talk about my own opinions though
they like I will state them I'll be okay
so here's the first hat for you the US
Department of Energy's Oak Ridge
National Laboratory conducted a study
with a team of researchers and they came
up with the conclusion that by 2040 a
lot of software engineers and developers
jobs would be replaced by AI there's a
high probability that would be the case
and the reason I don't think this should
scare you at least it doesn't scare me
is because Tech is constantly evolving
and changing there are so many jobs that
were around in the year 2000 that aren't
anymore that doesn't mean that those
people who have those jobs are jobless
it just means that hey if you didn't
grow your skills and grow your skill
sets and just enhance yourself in order
to keep up with the trends then yeah
maybe you got left behind but the people
who kept on progressing they were able
to keep up with the market Keeper of the
trends and keep their jobs and get
better jobs now when we think about AI a
lot of us do think about tattoo petite
because that's the you know hot new uh
really intelligent thing out right now
however other companies are creating
really cool experimental items as well
for example Microsoft created deep coder
which is a highly still experimental
tool but it allows for basically what I
just said for it to Output true code for
the solutions you're looking for if
coder can create a whole new application
for you by predicting what properties it
needs to provide the desired output
switches honestly very incredible okay
we're intent we're soft passengers or
want to be attacked let's Embrace tech
let's acknowledge that something's
really damn cool something really cool
you know what I mean and deep color very
much is also oversized commit assistant
AI helps developers while they code
while developers are programming this
tool identifies defects that is in their
code overall saving developers up to 20
of their time so I say this to say
whatever people are afraid of when we're
in it and so let's embrace it let's use
these tools because again saving 20 of
my time I appreciate it because time is
a limited resource and I can't be over
here wasting it for you know for no job
so how do we use this information to
stay relevant in the field and progress
and actually end up earning more money
because of our learning
[Music]
okay so so now that we've broken all of
this down how can we use this
information
to be better because if your question is
our software engineer is going to be
replaced by AI the answer is yes
if
you do not level up so let's talk about
how you can level up and how to change
your skill sets or what to learn if
you're actually just now starting to
code what to focus your efforts on so
that you can withstand the test of time
the director of AI at Tesla specifically
stated how most developers today they
collect claim manipulate and label their
code when it comes to creating complex
infrastructure many aren't doing that
basically the answer of how to stay
relevant is to lean very analytical and
like math heavy or lean very creative
let's break this down in the future
software developers are going to be very
data driven they are going to be feeding
lots of data in cleaning data to make
sure that their AI tools are very
intelligent instead of hard coding their
their Solutions because that's what the
AI is doing but the AI can work well or
smart without as much proper clean data
as possible understanding machine
learning and machine learning principles
along with data science principles is
also
key is crucial it is key to stay
relevant in this field and there's some
bad news for y'all and I think for many
that's going to include a lot of math AI
projects include algebra calculus
statistics really a lot a lot of math
y'all which I know is such bad news for
many people even myself because the last
time I took a math class was I sort of
got in high school a formal math class I
have not taken since high school I'ma
need to uh hit up those books a little
bit but you know we will talk about that
later now on the creative side if you
are in ux UI design or engineering this
could be a really great time for you
because yes AI is super analytical but
guess what it's not it's not that
creative it's really great at problem
solving it's not really great at uh yeah
let's create uh the best user experience
with these colors and these type of
things and everything and believe me
I've tried it does not do the best job
that's really where my skills make shine
so if you are that More Design focused
or the want like the creative side of
uxcy for example I worked a little bit
as a US engineer and I got to work super
closely with us UI designers and so if
that's if if knowing all of this I need
to make a decision for the future I
would would likely lead the More usui
Design side so now if you've gone
through this video and you're not really
uh
you're not feeling at peace because
you're like okay Naya I am not super
analytical I am not a huge math person
and also I'm not
I don't dive head in to design for
example that's honestly like me I like
the problem-solving side of things but
also like escaping from the problem
solving side of things doing the more
creative side of things and then escape
from a more creative side thing to do
the more uh problem solving things right
AI lacks is creativity like discussed
before problem solving and understanding
true business needs by positioning
yourself as a professional who can look
at all those things and create Solutions
based on the state of the economy the
state of your company the state of your
team and what the people users and
higher ups at your company need you very
much are in a very solid position you
will have a secure position here another
place where AI lacks is ethical
considerations that is really where
humans come in because ethics is not
black and white and when it comes to
computers they are day and night type of
tools when it comes to nuances that's
really where things can get difficult
and so by being that person who can
consider all of these things and bring
them constantly forward to your team and
establish yourself as a person who will
constantly look at all these different
things to enhance your tools and
resources that is going to do amazing
for you and if that's already what you
do then cool you can you know pop over
brewski and call it a day but many
people I think no matter where you're at
either creative analytical or in the
middle like I am liking both things
elevation is going to be needed to
survive in this Tech space so I say that
all to say don't be scared get excited
get motivated because if you are a
person who isn't um ready or willing to
constantly adapt and be a lifelong
Learner in general then to me there are
better places for you than Tech and
that's okay that is completely okay I'm
just saying no matter if AI was a thing
or not Tech forever is going to be ever
changing and so you need to be a person
who can change with it and stay relevant
in the field I hope that doesn't sound
harsh because I sincerely am not trying
for it to be it's sincerely it's just
like hey let's all level up let's all
get that bag and let's all uh that's all
learn and grow in the process you know
so to answer the question is AI going to
replace developers my answer is not if
you grow and enhance and level up your
skill sets too uh to keep up with these
changes people through these Trends this
is not something that hasn't happened
before like for example the.com bubble
back in the 2000s and I'm sure people
were left behind however here I am
learning to code in 2020 20 years after
that and getting a job because I was
able to learn the relevant skills needed
to uh to be here I promise I will help
you all do that along the way the next
few videos will be very much dedicated
towards being able to secure that
position and stay competitive in the
field so thank you so much for watching
I'm gonna walk around the park a little
bit yeah see y'all